international pressure crippling
sanctions and even the threat of war
so far nothing has discouraged iran from
its nuclear ambitions
some analysts say its determination is
part of tehran's strategy in addition to
the medical needs satiating the medical
needs of the country as well as uh you
know
of the needs of tomorrow
for the nuclear propulsion engine ships
uh this is also a punishment a response
actually to the west's hostility and to
the israelis hostilities this was
somehow a declaration of
a tit-for-tat policy from now on
iran has long desired nuclear technology
following the islamic revolution in 1979
most countries cut off all nuclear
cooperation with tehran and without
reliable foreign fuel supplies iran
started developing its own nuclear
program
but as a consequence it has been under
economic sanctions since the 1990s
the west has been suspicious of the
country's venture into nuclear energy
especially because of the high cost it
has paid
some experts also say it makes little
sense considering iran is among the
world's richest in natural resources but
iran says its goals are peaceful and it
needs nuclear power to diversify its
energy sector as its oil fields will
eventually be depleted
by giving up much control of its nuclear
activities with the 2015 deal iran has
also hoped to convince west that it only
means peace
we will need peaceful nuclear energy
sooner or later if we fail to address
these long-term issues today we will
face problems tomorrow but the west
imposes sanctions despite knowing our
nuclear energy project is peaceful
since u.s left the agreement in 2018
iran has deployed centrifuges that can
produce nuclear fuel more quickly and
brought its uranium enrichment program
closer to weapons grade level uranium
enrichment is a dual use technology
available for both civilian and military
purposes when uranium is enriched to
five percent it can fuel nuclear power
plants at twenty percent it can be used
in research reactors but 90 percent is
nuclear weapon grade and iran has
already embraced uranium up to 60
percent
western powers fear the ratio will only
rise as negotiations in vienna continue
to stall
there are serious concerns over iran's
nuclear program you know iran was
obviously
you know building a site at full day
that it did not declare you know the
whole nuclear crisis was kicked off
because it was working on natanz and
iraq which he did not declare and it was
revealed by the iranian opposition group
obviously when documents were
where you know the i expected options
they found you know uh linked to the
aquan network so there are serious
concerns around iran's nuclear program
which are legitimate some analysts say
just by having the technology that could
be used to make a bomb iran will
increase its sense of security and gain
political influence in the middle east
and its defiance of perceived western
hostility is a useful tool for its
leaders in domestic politics resource
al-jazeera tehran